breakfast so what's our plan beat him up
torture him friend phone no
do it my way
everybody is Charlie this is gonna be my
arrow episode two longbow hunters video
I'll also talk about the epic crossover
teaser that Stephen Amell dropped with
John Wesley Shipp wearing the 90s
classic version of his Barry Allen flash
suit careful for spoilers from the arrow
episode if you haven't seen it yet
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video arrow top 10 first then I'll
talk about the crossover promo starting
with number 10 it's the brand new intro
Stephen Amell does a brand new version
of the intro saying I'm not a hero I'm
inmate 4 5 8 7 I'm not the Green Arrow
anymore so it's a pretty big shift for
the series sometimes you forget how many
times they reuse the same version of the
intro so when they flip it up like this
it can be kind of fun like when they did
the Nora version in episode 1 of the
flash my name is Nora Allen 9 the intro
the longbow hunters with a heist to them
stealing Argus tech because Diaz is the
new 52 version of Richard dragon and his
team was the longbow hunters they're
kind of doing a version of that but
they're only doing a couple of the
characters so they're doing red dart
this guy is Kodiak that this person is a
new character called silencer guess what
her power is she's the one that
nullifies the sound within that field
around herself which they didn't do a
good job of paying off towards the end
of the episode during the double canary
cry fight we'll talk more about the
longbow hunters later this season
because I'm not really sure what their
arc is going to be if they're gonna be
taking them down earlier or if they're
gonna last into the back half of the
season
because the way they set them up at the
end of season 6 said they were supposed
to be this crazy League of Assassins
level team that was almost untouchable
they didn't quite come across that way
during the episode and like red dart for
instance by the end of the episode
reminded me of Baroness from the GI Joe
movies remember those awful movies she's
like the Hot Topic version of Baroness
so that's all I could think about when
red dart was wearing those right glasses
at the end I was like oh my god this is
right out of a GI Joe movie so hopefully
those characters get better by the end
of the season but they were just trying
to steal that prototype weapon the team
arrow was able to get back by the end of
the episode with Diggle and Argus eight
we get a first really big black siren
scene of the season she references Jerry
Conway she says the con
whay case gerry conway had just created
a whole bunch of DC characters but the
funny thing about this though is that
they may be including an easter egg
within an easter egg because they
actually had a character on the show
named Jerry Conway that was Felicity's
assistant when she was still running
Palmer tech but the whole thing that
they set up for her during the season is
that she's trying to get justice for
Quentin so because she's black siren but
she's also the DA she can't go rogue
that was a big thing for all the
characters in the episode like Diggle is
working at Argus so he has to play by
the rules but Felicity wants to get Diaz
so she breaks all the rules so black
siren was kind of doing the same thing I
did like the energy between Black Canary
and black siren I don't think they're
gonna be total [ __ ] to each other all
season but remember the whole thing is
as a black Canary's lover vigilante was
killed by black siren they kind of made
nice by the end of the episode but the
full culmination of their arc will be
Black Canary forgiving her for killing
Vince seven the joke about Oliver
joining bricks gang so he needs
information on Diaz from them but they
force him to take out one of the guards
that's been hounding him since he got
there the weird thing about this
storyline wasn't so much about what brig
bronze tiger and Cody Rhodes were trying
to do to oliver they were trying to get
him to go dirty do it the old-fashioned
way just take him out it was actually
Oliver's fanboy that keeps following him
around that had all these super dark
suggestions he's the one that suggested
threatening the guards family he
suggests blackmailing him to get him
fired so he just seems to have all these
crazy dark ideas for getting rid of
someone inside prison in all this access
to information that he's not supposed to
have access to for someone who was
framed and thrown in prison wrongfully
that was his whole deal in the first
episode for getting Oliver to protect
him I'm not supposed to be here I was
wrongfully in prison but somehow he just
seems super shady it's one of those
little finger tight plots where you make
yourself seem like a weak person but
secretly there's some bigger plan you
have in play six old Roy and William
talk it out we learned some details
about what else is going on in the
future Felicity and Oliver in the future
just left William on his own they don't
say that they're dead they imply that
felicity is still alive no idea about
Oliver but we learned that Felicity
purposefully sent William to LeAnn you
using
the hosen to find roy williams been very
active as an adult he says he spent over
a billion dollars trying to develop
affordable magnetic levitation so either
he's a genius in the future too or
Oliver gets some of his money back or
Felicity's companies Smoak technologies
becomes a really rich company that
allows him to spend that kind of money
trying to develop cutting-edge
technology five double Canaries versus
that longbow hunter silencer it was a
cool takedown I like the idea behind the
fight but I thought that number four
diggle's fight against Diaz was a little
bit better with the flamethrower on the
train just a little more tactile a
little bit more down and dirty and you
care a lot more about the two characters
that are fighting like you care about
black siren and Black Canary but I don't
really care about this silencer
character that they're fighting so we
didn't feel quite as epic as diggle's
fight on the train number three though
even bigger one afterwards because
Felicity just isn't having any of this
Argus play by the rules stuff she breaks
from Diggle so that's the end of their
alliance and goes back to the FBI agent
from last season I'm not really sure how
I feel about this either because I
wasn't a big fan of that FBI character
we'll see if they do something
interesting with her this season she was
really just an antagonist for all of her
last season just to push him to confess
to being green arrow which he did by the
end of the season so the whole set up
was is that she was going to help them
take down Diaz and felicity is just
picking that storyline back up like you
promised to help us now it's time for
you to make good on that there was this
weird thing going on with Diaz during
the episode where he was taunting Diggle
on the train so he's still very much a
big character in one of the bigger
villains of the season if not the big
bad of the season I don't know if
they've absolutely confirmed that
because it does seem like he's going to
be really big but we'll see how much
that pushes past the mid-season finale
because there's so much stuff happening
with the crossover and Oliver being in
prison that it feels like they're not
gonna take him down for good
till Oliver gets out and that's not
gonna be till the back half of the
season to old Roy and William dig up one
of the graves on Lian Yu
surprise turns out it's Oliver's bow
with a message hidden inside and of
course he burns it right away without
letting us look at it or William
I love Williams reaction hey what are
you doing there in that deep sigh that
Roy gives out like Jesus now I got to go
back to Star City
the thing about
and one of the reasons why I think that
it is him here the mystery green arrow
that we've been seeing all season is is
because when he sees the bow inside that
box he kind of knows where the note is
headed before he ever reads it early
theory is is that what's going on is
that Roy went to LeAnn you to get away
because he is the secret green arrow
here it ended very badly in our
present-day timeline in the aftermath of
whatever went wrong he went off to LeAnn
you to be by himself and look for
answers like he makes the joke to
William you're not gonna find any
answers here as if he's been trying to
find answers this whole time the next
time we flash-forward I think it's
implied that we'll be in future Star
City so it'll make a little more sense
and we'll see some of the other
characters from the future like maybe an
older version of Felicity and she'll
explain a little bit more about why it
is they needed to come back number one
though Oliver maintains some of his
integrity by getting rid of the guard
making them believe that he stabbed him
when really Oliver just did it himself
that seems to be his go-to thing right
now he's two for two he framed bronze
tiger during episode one now he's framed
the guards so we'll see how many more
people he frames while is in there let
me know in the comments though what did
you think of the longbow hunters and the
way they're setting up some of these
arcs and why Roy is going back to Star
City but crossover promo we got too
freaked out about this John Wesley Shipp
in the classic 90s version of his Barry
Allen costume making me wonder if during
this crossover because it's Elseworlds
and we'll see other versions of the
characters if we're seeing him play
Barry Allen from another earth who just
grew up wearing a costume like this
remember the multiverse teaser that we
got way back during season two when they
were going to earth to for the first
time you get a teaser flash of John
Wesley Shipp in his 90s Barry Allen
costume and it's not Jay Garrick it's a
version of Barry Allen from another
earth that just looks like John Wesley
Shipp but it's probably one of the most
nostalgic things that they've ever done
so you have Stephen Amell in a flash
costume you have John Wesley Shipp in
the 90s flash costume and obviously
Grant Gustin wearing the green arrow
costume we got that new flash episode
posting tomorrow I'll do my video after
it airs leave all your video requests in
the comments below there's just a whole
bunch of stuff happening this week so
it's gonna be crazy
click here for the new flash
trailer and click here to learn about
mutants inside the MCU before Avengers 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]